Don’t be fooled by the big-mouthed basking
shark’s sluggish demeanor.
While it spends most of its time slowly slurping
its way through plankton-filled waters,
every once in a while this mammoth fish—the
second largest in the sea—hurls its body
entirely out of the water
A team of international scientists used video
analysis and an animal-instrumented data logger
to measure the vertical velocity of basking
shark breaches, off the coast of Ireland.
In this video, the researchers have equipped
a male basking shark with an accelerator.
In just ten beats of its tail—or 9 seconds—the
fish propels itself from a depth of 28 meters
to the water’s surface, at a near-vertical angle
In the study, they clocked some of the breaching
speeds at up 5 meters per second—just a
scooch faster than their great white shark cousins.
And these jumps are energetically costly
for the plankton-eaters.
Scientists estimate that a single breach costs the
basking shark 50% more of their daily
caloric intake than great whites of a similar size.
It’s thought that great white sharks breach to snatch
meals lingering near the ocean's surface. Why filter-
feeding sharks exhibit this behavior is not known.
Basking sharks might be trying to rid themselves
of parasites, ward off predators, or perhaps
court mates in nearby waters.
But, regardless of the reason, researchers
believe these new data should shift our perspective
on other supposedly slow-going creatures.